I want to talk about the ending of the
film because in real life the buddy Dane
show never integrated but you made the
choice that well I thought I had to give
it a happy ending you know what really
happened is the white integrationist
crashed black day and went on camera and
it went off the air the kids we're all
blue-collar was pretty much blue-collar
baltimore show and their parents do you
think today if kids still slow dance
that there would be a local TV show on
where black and white kids slow dance at
13 and 14 years old
I don't know I don't know if that would
even be today possible which just goes
to show that that movie is still you
know and now the integrated couples are
the thing that is and that was the
sequel that never got made was about
their prejudice today really so I I
think that the what what hairspray says
is still pretty much out there and
subjects we're still dealing with it's a
lot better in some ways in some ways
it's the same that hit me a bit so I'm
just gonna take a second you know
sitting in a theater in 1988 and
watching this film and even then you
know it's a movie that still feels
contemporary because the way you
approach the issues but watching it then
I can't imagine just how you're laughing
but you're crying and then you're just
going what the [ __ ] is wrong with us you
know well but that's how you make a
point always is make people laugh if
you're standing up there preaching if I
had preached in this movie no we
wouldn't be here today
but if you make somebody laugh and
underneath it that's why I said it was a
Trojan horse it snuck in all the values
this movie encouraged gay marriage
basically it encouraged your right kids
to date black guys did actually
something that today it still plays in
every high school in America the musical
who would imagine that that could ever
happen you can mix the word music I'm
going to talk about that for a second
because this I consider this a musical
because when you play music the point
kind of is to dance and there's a lot of
dancing in this film
not so much singing but talk to me about
building this as a musical and did you
guys all go through dance training Ricky
were you just like a born a trained
dancer nobody in the film really was a
lot but we had you were yeah well you do
the roach really the best in it I kill
the road she kills that number oh wait a
second I heard a story that you pitched
by demonstrating all the dancing oh I
could do the dances you sent me a VHS
before we started him doing all of them
like potatoes give me a martini I'll do
the Madison liquor that's the last time
I dance please bury it and uh you know I
still go to the reunions they still have
the reunions in Baltimore of the people
that were on the show and it's amazing
there's 70 75 years old doing the roach
without irony perfectly and it's great
to see you know they still have reunions
and still go and some and those people
that are on the show taught the
choreographer at low
I'd love to the dances to do them
because these were all real dances none
of them were made up for the movie even
the bug all those they were real dances
kill that roach everybody didn't want to
stop dancing John yeah I did not want to
stop and everybody was so sad when it
wrapped they just wanted it were you
here in the middle of the movie when we
had the best party I've ever had on a
hole on a movie set ever it was just a
spontaneous party halfway through on
this pier and all the kids started
wildly doing the dances it was really
fun it was a great party no commotion
yeah yeah that wasn't even in the movie